okay so thanks russell so thank you all
for coming
and um um let me just say a few words
about the upcoming boot camp
two days i'm going to give three
lectures go back to san diego because i
got to complete this program summer
program
and in the next four days uh so the last
talk of today will be given by thor
hustfeld
if we will talk about the exact uh
we will talk about exact algorithms for
np complete problems
and subsequently russell will talk about
the randomization
orion will talk about um connections
between
satisfiability and circuit lower bounds
and virginia will talk about complexity
theory of p
and especially the emerging complexity
theory of p
and finally daniel marks will talk about
parameters complexity
so we have a full full schedule four
talks a day
for five days for five days of the week
so um
okay so i changed the title
not the contents of the of the talk
the talk was labeled titled satisfiable
algorithms one and two
but but if you think about it it's the
combinatorial properties of the kc and f
that are central to both lower bounds
and upper bounds in this area
and i want to take a look at some of the
key properties of kcnf
that led to various interesting results
and that's the
those are the first two talks okay and i
would like to thank my co-authors
russell
mike sachs paul pudlach and our students
francis zane
chris calabro william matthews and
and the future students and the and the
current students
okay so um
so that's uh that's overview of the talk
and uh
those are the three combinatorial
properties i will talk about and talk
about the consequences
and uh some of the talk
the talk will mostly focus on intuition
towards the very end
i'll become more and more sketchier but
the first two parts
i i hope to give you a very good sense
about
a very good sense about ideas and
applications so what's the general
motivation so it's about satisfiability
problem
and the general motivation is faster
algorithms
that's all for sat solvers for example
okay
but more importantly want to understand
the structure of the kcnf
and which which might explain uh
which it turns out kind of explains so
the complexity of many other problems
and also the lower bounds
okay so these are the general law so
general motivation and
so let me give you a much more specific
motivation for this talk
my foray into satisfiable algorithms is
motivated by depth three circuit lower
bounds
and in particular so the motivation is
so this is after uh uh this is post
hastas lemma where
where where one has proved uh very
strong exponential time lower bounds
for parity uh function for for constant
depth ac 0 circuits
and so the goal here is to prove even
stronger lower bounds
and so that's a kind of the so that's a
technical goal and i will show you
how it is motivated by other more
sophisticated circuit models
so we have these depth three circuits so
you had the top
level top level you have or gate
followed by a bunch of and gates at the
second level and at the bottom level you
have or gates
okay and we also specialize these
circuits when we restrict the fan in at
the bottom to be k
and then we call them as sigma pi sigma
sub k circuits
okay so this is so this is the circuit
model
and our motivation is to prove strong
lower bounds
so what's known so far okay prior to
1997
okay and so switching lamar tells us
that parity requires 2 to the c times
square root and
size for computing okay where c is
strictly less than one
and subsequently
powerland and johan improved that lower
bond using a top-down technique
which is only applicable for depth three
circuits it's not clear how to apply it
to
depth four circuits uh to get a slightly
better lower bound
of two to the zero point six eight seven
times square per parity
but on the other hand parity so the best
known upper bounds
are of the form fourth root of n times
two to the square root n
for depth three circuits and with uh
with the bottom fan in of square root
okay
so one concrete motivation is that can
we reduce the gap
between lower and upper bounds for
parity for depth three circuits
so the talk will focus on this very
technical
and interesting question and uh and see
what progress we can make
so let me give you one more motivation
for depth three circuit lower bounds
if you look at larger circuit models
like linear size log depth
and it turns out they can be decomposed
into uh
so they can be written as depth three
circuits
with a large fan in at the top level and
um
and uh somewhat uh somewhat small fan in
at the bottom level
so in particular cn size uh dela
so d log and depth circuits can be it
can be written as
two to the little off and size depth
three circuits where the bottom fan end
is
bounded by and to the little of one
so even more um if you restrict the
circuits even further
to make them series parallel so you can
get a uh
somewhat more simpler circuit so for
example that uh
so you so there's a trade-off between
the bottom fan in and the top fanning
and so the trade-off behaves in that
fashion
so the difference between the previous
and this result is that uh
so the fanning could be constant at the
bottom level and
so you have to pay somewhat higher
penalty
or so you so you have to have a higher
fan out
of a fan in for the top gate
so similarly you can take nc1 circuits
and decompose them into depth d circuits
and uh and the size and the size behaves
so
um the fan in and the size are related
in that fashion
so the point here is that if you take
more more standard circuit models
they can be decomposed into so they can
be written as uh small depth circuits
with very very large size okay so that's
important point and
so uh one way to think about it is that
by large i mean for depth three circuits
you can look at the following
quantity take the log of the top gate
fan in
take the bottom gate fan in take the
product the product is typically
a one or more so
those are the kind of circuits we're
looking at for parity that it achieves
exactly one
for all these other circuit models the
product is much larger than one
but whereas if you look at the switching
lemma proofs it was only
able to prove lower bounds for circuits
where the product is less than one
so once again it's so the cut off point
is that
the product of the bottom fan in times
the log of the
top gate planet so the goal here is that
can we prove
can we break through that barrier and
prove stronger lower bounds
where the product is greater if the
product is
n product is n sorry
so as a fraction of n it's one yeah
right
okay so let's take a somewhat more
concrete
um um so this is basically the goal
so can we prove tight lower bonds for
parity
or can we prove lower bounds that exceed
this
trade-off between the bottom fan in and
the top fan
so i will now now will
go to the circuit uh we'll go to
satisfiability problem
and and i will introduce the
satisfiability problem
and try to connect these two problems
so when k is square root n so 2 to the
square root in
the is the cutoff point
so we are given a formula or a circuit
um
and uh and you want to check it is
satisfiable and
so the examples are kcnf um cnf
and formulas and ac 0 circuit and c1
circuit poly size circuit
so this is the general satisfiability
problem and
and we know that we can decide this in
time
time the size of the formula times 2 to
the n by by doing exhaustive research
and the goal is to see whether we can
improve upon this exhaustive search
can we obtain if can we obtain savings
over
the brute force method and one way to
express the complexity is
the size of the formula times 2 to the n
times some some factor that factor let's
call it 1 minus mu
and mu is the savings that we can get
get over the exhaustive search
so so we are specifically interested in
the class of kcnf circuits
and it turns out better satisfiability
algorithms for these problems
are seem to be connected with lower
bounds and
and and and also see
and more importantly combinatorial
properties of kcnf seem to be related
to both lower and upper bounds
so the best known prior to 1997 is so
the satisfiability savings is one in two
to the k
so you take each class try out all
possible possible settings
and and then you develop the dpl tree
and then show that you can get a
savings
okay so let me now quickly show you the
connection between
between uh the status between the kcnf
properties
and lower bonds so this is motivated
this is inspired by the top-down
approach of johan and powell
and where they try to improve the parity
lower bonds by using
a top-down approach and we use a
somewhat similar approach
so let's take a circuit sigma pi sigma k
circuit
with the top fanniness okay
and let's assume so let's focus on the
parity function for now
and this circuit computes the parity
function let's assume that
so and it turns out by simple argument
so one of the sub circuits which is the
kcnf
must accept at least 2 to the n over so
many
many inputs of odd parity and reject all
inputs of even parity
the top gate is an or gate so therefore
the bottom gates are
doing much of the computation much of
the filtering out
much of the filtering out of even uh
inputs
and the top gate is summing up all the
so
taking the union of all the efforts of
the kcns
all the kcnfs together must account for
all inputs
of odd parity and each one of the kcnfs
must reject even inputs
so that's the kind of constraint we have
in the circuit so therefore we can say
one of the circuits must accept at least
that many inputs
so the argument so the top-down argument
goes like this so if we understand kcnfs
well enough
maybe we can argue that a kcnf cannot
accept too many inputs
of odd parity while rejecting all inputs
of even parity
okay so that's the strategy and uh so
what do we know about kcnfs
okay so that's where we begin so this is
where we started our question
uh powell and uh and we we started
thinking about
um what do we know about kcnfs to
uh to make uh uh how to make
so to obtain a strong lower bounds okay
so the starting point is the following
thing
so if you look at if you look at the
kcnf with the
with the previous property that it is
accepting some odd inputs
while rejecting all even inputs so you
can look at
all the uh all the inputs that it is
accepting
or satisfying and they are such that
those those satisfying assignments are
isolated so that means if you flip one
of the bits
then you get a then you get an
assignment which is rejected by the kcnf
because it's an even because it's an
even input
okay so we call such solutions isolated
if the hamming distance is within
hamming distance
if you flip one of the bits so the the
corresponding assignment is a false
assignment
okay so what we are asking is that what
is the maximum number of isolated
solutions for the kc and
so this is somewhat general question if
we can get a tight bone on this
then we can get a tight lower bond for
parity
so by using the top-down argument
okay so we show that this number is
precisely
or this number is actually precisely 2
to the n times 1 minus 1 over k
so if you look at the block parity
circuit for constructing parity with dep
for depth 3 circuits they achieve this
bond
and so how do we prove that and
so that's um so once we prove that so
then we will be able to show that
sigma pi sigma k circuits with bottom
fan in k
must must necessarily have a must
necessarily need
2 to the n over k k c and f to compute
parity
so each case c and f can accept that
many r inputs and together
we need 2 to then over k so if you look
at the product of the
log of the top fan in which is n over k
times k
so that's n take it as a fraction of
n so that's it's one and that's that's
basically where this
ah where this bound meets okay
so let me show you how we can show such
a property and uh
and uh and it's obviously that so
so the nice thing in computer science is
that when we can prove properties by
means of algorithms
okay so we'll come up with an algorithm
that that shows
that that the number of isolated
solutions cannot be too large
so one property of the kcnf
when you're when you have an isolated
solution is the following thing
so fix any isolated solution so let's
call it x
okay so look at ah plug in the values of
this assignment
x into the formula so look at each class
some classes turn out to be minimally
satisfiable
see since it's a satisfying assignment
every clause is satisfied
and not only that some clauses are
minimally satisfied by that i mean
there are some clauses where where
where all the literals except one or
zero
and it turns out um
so we call such such clauses critical
clauses
for this assignment x
and it's not only that that for each
variable
there must be a critical clause at this
assignment
so when you have an isolated solution
for each variable you have at least one
critical clause
and all the critical clauses are
distinct
if you were to flip that variable so if
there is no critical clause if you were
to flip that variable
so the formula must become false and the
only way it can become false is that
there exists a clause where this
variable is so literal
or the corresponding literally so
literal okay
so we first make this simple observation
that uh
that there are um there must be at least
one critical clause
for each variable at a satisfying
assignment which is isolated
so what we are going to do is that one
so we are going to take advantage of the
critical clauses
to compress the solution so we have a
shorter code for the solution
for this isolated solution so given that
we have critical clauses
so the idea is that if you know that all
of them are zero but but for one
so you can guess somehow if you know the
other variables and their values
then you know this variable must be one
and then you can
so you can you can determine its value
so this is like the unit clause
heuristic okay so to
to put this into practice so what we're
going to do is that
we take a kcnf we take a permutation so
let's fix an isolated solution
okay and so we use the following
so we use the following algorithm to
compress the solution x
so we fix a permutation and um
and um uh
so we so we look at uh um
so we look at the next bit according to
the permutation
if there is a clause
that contains this variable as a unit
class so that means if there's a clause
that only contains this variable
then we know that clause that variable
must be set to one
so we set that variable so rather than
setting the variable we simply delete
that particular variable from the
satisfying assignment
so so we're going to get rid of some of
the bits from x
it's based on this permutation and
and the resulting string is the
compressed tree
so the idea is that so we're going to
show that this is a one to one function
we can recover the string x from the
compressed string
so let me show you the recovery
algorithm and
i'm sorry does the representation need
to contain
or do you need to express which clauses
are the critical clauses
because is it possible some of them
aren't critical so we are given the
solution x
okay and we are given a permutation so
we go through each
bit in that order and if that bit is not
needed
and if that bit position and if the bit
value is implied by the formula then we
delete that bit
you mean the critical clause for that
bit or any critical clause containing
that one
there's any critical clause yeah that
contains that one but then
we don't need to know what the critical
this is to create a represent a
compressed representation right so don't
you need to know
which clauses are the critical clauses
all right
for in order to get the representation
back
so right so we're given the input x so
therefore we can
so we know what the critical clauses are
so i think he's asking
how do you know if there's a critical
cause containing x
and the way you know it is by that point
since all the
we're looking for critical clauses where
all the very other variables have
already been appeared
have already appeared that means all the
other variables will have been sent to
false
and so that cause when simplified at
that point will just be asked itself
but you need to know that that's a
critical cause well we're saying
that it is self-evident so that means
when it becomes only a unit class
yeah every time it becomes size one that
is a critical cause it might be
if it yeah so what i'm doing is that i'm
mapping okay
i remember i had input x okay so and we
know it's a satisfying solution we know
it is isolated solution
so there will be critical clauses for
that input so
so the only issue is that which bits of
x are redundant
given the formula and given the
permutation so that we can determine
given we map this x to the compressed x
by going through the bits in that order
and figuring out which bits are implied
and critical clauses are the ones that
will help us in this regard
so we have all the knowledge here so
this is this
right so then i will show you how to
recover x given this compressed string
so of course we need to know the
permutation so the permutation is given
and the formula is given
and the compressed string is given so
then i will show you how to recover
so that kind of shows given the
permutation and the formula we have a
one-to-one mapping
between between isolated solutions and
compressed strings
so this is what i do i'll start with the
formula
okay and um
i
and if the formula has a unit class
then i know for the formula to be true
that unit class must be set to 1.
so therefore i said to 1. okay sorry
i'm going to look at the variables in
that order
and if the next variable has a unit
class in the restricted formula
so then i'm going to set that variable
to or to the appropriate value
and if there's no such unit class then i
take the bit
from the compressed string then i will
set that bit
so so the idea is that so the
permutation is telling me so i'm going
to give an explanation a second to see
why
why
and and how often this is going to work
so either the bit is implied in which
case i can deduce it from the formula
or if the bit is not implied i i will
take it from the contrast string
okay and so then i recover x it's
basically the reverse process
and it's a one to one mapping
so the main issue is that what can we
say about
the length of the compressed string so
what
are what the satisfiability coding lemma
says is that fix any
fix any isolated solution if you take a
random permutation
so the average compressed length is
basically 1 minus 1 over k fraction of
the total length
so the argument is the following thing
it's a very simple argument one line
kind of one line proof and if you uh so
take
so take the satisfying assignment x
which is isolated
so therefore it has a critical clause
for each variable
okay so if you take a random and fix a
variable i
and if you take a random permutation the
probability that variable appears after
all the corresponding variables in its
critical clause is 1 in k
so each clause has length k and look at
the corresponding critical clause for
the variable i
and of the k variables there are so the
critical variable
is likely to appear to be the last
variable among them with probability 1
and k
so therefore with probability 1 in k
so this particular variable can be
compressed or can be deleted from the
string
so therefore the total so total average
savings is n times 1 minus 1 hour
so so the total savings is one k one in
k fraction
so so so from this it easily follows
so um so there exists so so there are at
most
2 to the n times 1 minus 1 over k
solutions which are isolated
and so we know that average a compressed
length is at most n minus n over k
and we know so therefore there exists
one permutation
such that the average overall compress
such that average overall isolated
solutions
is is still n times n minus okay
so the point is that for a particular
permutation
and for a particular isolate a
particular isolation solution
might be compressed but for some other
solution not be compressed
so we reverse the quantifiers and we
show that there exists basically one
one uh one so there's at least one
permutation
uh that has the so that has average
length overall isolated solutions
okay
so by using a simple argument so we have
a kind of coding argument that uh
prefix free prefix free encoding
argument that shows
that the number of solutions so what we
are shown is that
so there is a permutation such so that
maps and that maps isolated solutions to
compress strings
such that the average length is 1 minus
1 over k
times n and uh so then we can
so use the fact to argue that the total
number of solutions is at most
so two to the n times one hour okay
so that's that's basically the
satisfiability coding lemma
and uh so from that
so we conclude that uh sigma pi sigma k
circuits
if the bottom front end is bounded by k
so then
so then a parity takes two to the normal
case size
precise so you want to extend it
so the sigma pi sigma k model has the
restriction that the fan in is bounded
by k
so you want to extend it to include to
include arbitrary circuits
and and what we show is that when
there's no restriction on the bottom fan
in
okay that three circuits must take
fourth root of n
times two to the square root and size
so this is basically up to a constant
factor so even
that so even the constant factor is off
by a two or
four okay so this is this is the lower
bond for computing parity which meets
the upper bound
within a small factor
so to go beyond to go from restricted
circuits
um to a more general bottom fan in
circuits so we have to
look at uh um so we had to look at uh
so we have to generalize the notion of
isolated circuits and
so use the weight argument weighted
argument i will go through that in a
second
and uh and so the problem is that the
previous argument says
that when the clause lengths are uniform
so you have one in k
chance that a that a variable so that a
particular variable becomes unit class
okay now the clause lengths are varied
so if you take general depth three
circuits clause links are varied
some may have large class length ah some
may be very short
and you want to kind of argues over all
these things so
let me simply quickly generalize and and
we do know
for every solution there are critical
clauses for every variable okay
so let's look at the number of so let's
group the critical clauses by their
length
okay let's use this quantity n sub l of
x to be the number of critical clauses
of length l so we can now
so we know that the sum of the sum of
the critical clauses should be equal to
n because there is one for each variable
and we define the weight to be 1 over
the inverse
of the length
of one over the length of the of the
critical clauses
so you basically uh so this is going to
be the weight and
and previously our weight is an overhead
okay now and now this is whatever it is
there could be more than one critical
clause per variable
so you just pick one pick one and then
and make the argument
so we will see in a few slides how we
can exploit so the existence of more
than one critical class
so we are going to make a twofold
argument so first of all that
so there cannot be too many solutions
with weight greater than
uh greater than a particular number
the same argument as before we are
generalizing it
before mu before mu was n over k
now mu is whatever it is and we are
going to fix an appropriate mu in a
second
and make kind of generalize the previous
argument that you cannot have too many
isolated solutions
okay so um
so let's make the argument okay so this
um so we have a depth three circuits
a circuit that computes parity so
therefore it's accepting
two to the n minus one odd inputs while
rejecting all other inputs
and um um um
so for each input there must exist a kcn
there must exist a cnf that accepts it
because of the top-down argument
and so we look at uh the weight of that
input
that particular assignment x so we're
going to choose mu to be square root n
plus log n over four
so that's where the fourth root energy
is going to come so we're going to
balance
balance between uh between between
those inputs so those isolated solutions
that have uh short critical clauses
versus
those that have long critical clauses so
the point is that
if you have a short critical clause
okay you cannot so you cannot accept too
many isolated solutions
but on the other hand if you have long
critical clauses
that critical clause can only be
critical for so many of the isolated
solutions
so the problem is that for a particular
input we can argue that you need to have
one critical clause for each variable
but the same critical clause might might
work for many other inputs
or for many other odd inputs
so we're going to argue if a clause is
too long if a critical clause is too
long it cannot be critical
for too many of the too many of the
inputs of odd length
so that's the balance we are trying to
draw between the two things okay
so mu is the cutoff point so we look at
the inputs
okay we look at the solutions or the
satisfying assignments of the
of this depth three circuits uh circuit
with weight at least mu
and the rest
so we know that um
um
so so we focus on the so large weight
inputs
so that's a set of s1 and
and we know we know that
each k c and f can only say i i can only
accept 2 to the n minus mu of such
inputs
so therefore that so to accept all the
inputs in s1
so we need at least that many kcnfs
so we have fewer of them so then we
can't capture all those inputs
so then then we make the argument um
so those inputs that have low weight
they can only they can always accept
many uh so many
uh so many
right so long critical clauses can only
be critical for so many inputs
so that's what i meant to say and and so
that's
so for for something to be a critical
clause you need to select one of the
variables
that is going to be the true variable or
true literal and the remaining are all
zero
so there's so many ways you can make
that happen so therefore that is l times
two to the n minus
2 to the n minus l solution variable
pairs
can be handled by a long critical class
so we get so we get this uh
so this quantity that for each of the
inputs
for each of the isolated solutions with
the small weight
so we need that many clauses at the
bottom level
so the total size is going to be there
is going to be the sum of the kc and f's
plus the sum of the bottom level gates
so you can have a lot of bottom level
gates
thereby reduce the number of kc and fs
but but then bottom level gates when
they are wide they cannot accept too
many inputs
or they cannot act as critical clauses
for too many inputs
so we balance these two things and
and so we get the desire
so that give us precisely fourth root of
n
times two to the square root and lower
bond for parity function
okay so that's the lower bond coming
from the satisfiable decoding lemma
and we can turn this into a
satisfiability algorithm very quickly
so this is how the satisfiable algorithm
works ppc
which is we take the formula and we take
a random assignment
and if the unit clause we
we so we deduce the value of that
variable
so to be one to off that literal to be
one otherwise
we randomly guess the value of the next
variable
so by using very similar and um
and uh um so we'll simplify the formula
and we repeat it through uh and we go
through all the variables in this
fashion
and we get an assignment in this fashion
and if
these and if i feel satisfied in the
process we output the assignment
okay
so the argument says so this so this
this polytime algorithm produces a
satisfying assignment
with the probability at least so 2 to
the minus n
plus the degree of isolation of x
the number of the number of assignments
which deviate
in truth value from that of x is over k
for any satisfying solution
so when l of x equals n for an isolated
solution
so we get a savings of n over k so
that's a satisfaction
so so the proof is again very simple it
follows from the previous
kind of arguments and um
so to get the particular savings so we
want
so we want two events to be satisfied
okay one is that
that for sufficiently many critical
clauses
or for sufficiently many critical
clauses
the critical variable appears as the
last among each set of variables
according to the random permutation
so that event happens um with
probability at least one in n
and given that happens what is the
probability we set the other variables
to correct values
and we set the other variables to
correct values with the probability half
we don't have any other information so
therefore we get
the total of probability to be so 2 to
the minus n plus and over k
can you can you just slow down to run
through that again
okay so what so so the algorithm
kind of works the following way so we
take a run impermetation
and write a permutation of the variable
names
the random permutation of the variables
okay
and we look at the next variable in that
order
see if there is a unit clause for that
variable we set the variable according
to the unit class
so that's if it's the if that's the only
way to keep satisfying that clause you
set that variable
make it true so you didn't have to do
any decisions
that was forced you got these forced
decisions essentially
right so that's four yeah and for non
for
and if there's no unit clause for that
variable we simply guess its value
with equal probability okay so
then and then the next series okay so
that's
so that's basically the assignment if
that process results in a
satisfied formula so then we output the
assignment to be clear this is the same
thing as unit propagation you just
arrived at it from theoretical
perspective is that right
yeah simplification by unit class yeah
so that's
in a random ordering random ordering
choice of
next variable
okay l x that's the degree of
degree of isolation we generalized it so
let l of x denote the number of
solutions
which are false within hamming distance
one so that's the degree of isolation
okay when it's fully isolated of course
l of x equals n
and and so you just run uh show the
proof part okay
so let's go through the proof slowly
okay so
what is that we want so we want a good
permutation
a permutation is good provided
that it that it will
create create an overkill unit clauses
and when are we guaranteed to create a
unit class
so so take a look at the unit class
the critical variable appears
as the last variable among the set of
variables in that class
the probability is 1 in k and we want
so the average number of such variables
is an over k
a permutation is good when we can
achieve that average number
uh oh okay so this is an event over the
choice of
right so so the event even basically
looks at
looks for good permutations those
permutations that achieve the average
uh savings and so you want to know what
the probability is
and having achieved the average savings
then you want to set the remaining bits
correctly
and and each bit is set correctly with
probability half
okay and
so simple argument shows its markov
inequality
um shows that uh that with probability
one in n
so we do get a permutation that um that
achieves
that achieves that achieves an average
number of unit clauses
which is n over k or lx over k
and the conditional probability is
is basically what is the probability of
guessing the remaining bits correctly
it seems strange that l x appears
positively in this formula like you
this is the probability the more the
more isolated the solution is the easier
it is to find
you would think that right so the
probability will increase the more
isolated it is so the probability will
increase
is there is there some way to account
for it because if the solution is not as
if there's like a lot of variables that
could go either way and still it's a
solution seems like that should also
make it easier to find just because
there's so much space
in which it exists is there right so
so your intuition is right and and i
will talk about it in a second
so if there are more solutions so you
are saying that
that it should be easier to find under
and so
um right
so this is the probability of finding a
particular solution
rather than finding any solution
so we can take the sum of the
probabilities and uh and
so that's going to the total probability
that's where the savings will come
okay so yeah this is important that uh
yeah so that
we are focusing on the probability of
outputting a particular solution
okay so that's the probability of
success and
and so let me um
so let's think more generally so we are
talking about a
we're talking about a solution with a
degree of isolation of l of x
and we have certain probability of
success but
of course in general k c and f need not
have isolated solutions
and uh and so we're going to argue that
that uh um that there is a combinatorial
property here okay
of any set of solutions that that will
help us in this regard so let me um
let me simply so define for each
for each point in the boolean cube
define this as a
for each point in the solution space of
the kcnf
so let me define this uh for this
quantity called
value of x which is 2 to the minus
n so plus l of x
and it turns out the sum of the values
over a
the set of satisfying solutions assuming
it's at least one
so the formula that the size of s that
the size of s
is at least one that the sum of uh sum
of the values is at least one
so a simple induction will prove that
okay
so that means where the solution so the
idea is the following thing so either
there are so there's at least one
isolated solution of course in which
case the value is high
because of the degree of isolation or
there are many solutions which are not
isolated
so then again they all contribute small
value they all sum up to be at least one
so now we can sum over so that means
when we have many solutions
okay we can look at the probability of
each solution
being output and sum over all the
probabilities
and due to that fact that we have so
that quantity will be
so that sum is exactly the same as
before
so we can generalize it from isolated
solution to a general kcnn
so there's more we can say to talk about
the intuition that we have what happens
when you have
many solutions okay we can do a somewhat
more detailed analysis
to show that when you have many
solutions so that so the dimension
essentially reduces
n is the size of the problem or the
dimension of the problem
when you have as many solutions so the
dimension becomes n minus log s
then you get savings on top of that
so that means if you can randomly guess
okay
okay if there are many solutions you can
randomly guess one and then you are
likely to be that's likely to be a
satisfying solution
and if you don't have many solutions so
then you have isolated
um solution case that so that was the
previous intuition
so now we are going to argue so using a
so using an iso parametric inequality
the worst way to organize
points is in a sub cube
so you pack all the points in a sub cube
that's the worst possible scenario for
this algorithm
and so that achieves that kind of lower
bond so that kind of upper bound in the
satisfiable target
so this is one of the unique properties
of this ppg algorithm many other
algorithms don't necessarily share this
property
so that as the solutions increase so
that's it so this algorithm gets better
so worst case is when there's a unique
solution
okay so that's
that's the first part of the
so let me continue and complete so let
me take up the
point that what happens when we have
many critical clauses
can we improve the algorithm
so we relied on the fact there is at
least one critical clause
for each variable at the satisfying
solution which is isolated
okay and there could be more than one
and in which case so let's take the
example so let's assume that our
satisfying solution is 1 to the n
that means the critical clauses will
have the particular format
one variable will be positive okay one
literal will appear positively
the remaining literals will appear
negatively because for the critical
cause to be minimal at that point
so uh it should be one followed member
followed by a bunch of zeros so
therefore the critical clause will look
like that
so and uh so now we can make the
following
following calculation what is a given a
random permutation
what is the probability that x1 will
appear as the last variable
in the first clause or the second class
so this probability is not one and three
it is slightly better than one and three
so it's 7 15 rather than 1 and 3.
so so we can get improvement over the
ppc algorithm assuming that we have at
least two critical clauses
that have that kind of structure where
the variables but for x1 are distinct
but of course in general we cannot
expect more than one critical class
there's no guarantee that we have a for
so that the formulas have more than one
critical clause
and it turns out so even then
so we can manufacture critical process
by using resolution
okay so it may be that uh solar so let's
look at the like
let's look at the lucky situation we
have we have a critical clause for x1
and and we have a critical clause for x2
we can resolve between the two to
produce another class
which is critical for x1
so we can manufacture additional
critical class for x1 by using
resolution
and now if you compute the probability
of appearing
as the last variable in a random
permutation for the first critical
clause or the
or the resolved one the probability will
be more than one third
so once again we can improve
but again there's no guarantee that
we'll have such nice critical clauses
that will help us resolve to get another
critical class
okay so um
so for example things things may go bad
we may get unlucky
the the critical clause for x2 might
have x1 complement in it
then we can't resolve them so we got
stuck
and this is this is in fact and there's
a reason
so the and the situation cannot be
remedied especially when we have a
solution at distance 2
from x so we have x
which is all ones so flip the first two
bits so we get another
uh we get another we get another
assignment assume that assignment is
also satisfying
in which case we cannot uh
we cannot hope to resolve and find a new
critical class
so to improve the algorithm so what we
are going to do is that we are moving
are going to look at a we are first
going to look at a special case
the special case is that de-isolated
solutions
so that means the solution is not only
isolated but but within distance one
so there are no solutions that's what
isolation means we look at distance d
in terms of hamming distance and we
stipulate there are no solutions
so such a solution called de-isolated
solution
so we assume the isolator solution and d
is going to be
sufficiently large that's all we care
about for our analysis for our algorithm
and and then we can now guarantee
basically additional critical clauses
through the resolution
okay so let me give an example how this
goes
so now now let's look at an assignment
that is at distance 2.
since this is not a satisfying
assignment and once you plug that into
the formula
the formula will become false okay
and uh so the critical clause for x1
still cannot be false because
because it has x1 or x2 complement
since you flipped x1 as well as x2 that
clause will still be true
but there must be some other clause that
must have been falsified
so we take that falsified clause and
resolve it with the critical clause for
x1
and manufacture another critical clause
for x1
and so we show that we can always do
that
because i'm only giving an example here
if you think about it we can always do
that
i and as long as we have a de-isolation
so for example
so there must be some clause like x1 or
x2 or x4 complement
to make that formula false at distance
two
okay and now now we resolve c4 with the
critical clause for x1
so to get this clause um to get another
critical class
so now we can use the previous argument
and show the forcing probability or
finding the unit clause
uh the probability of finding a unit
clause will improve upon one
will improve upon one over three and
that's good enough for us
so this is the intuition behind to go
beyond ppc
and to get a small savings okay
so similarly we can show that even if
you forgot to flip
uh the first bit and the uh um
second yeah even if you were to flip the
second bit we can get
uh we can get another critical clause
and uh and uh
so with that intuition so let me so let
me generalize the ppj algorithm in the
following way
so we what we are essentially going to
do is that
we take the formula and we do an s
bounded resolution before we start
the pp's algorithm then we take a random
permutation
then we examine the bits in that order
and whenever we find a unit clause we
force that variable or we take that
variable for free
and otherwise we guess the value so same
algorithm except we do some
pre-processing
before we start and the pre-processing
is called s-bond resolution
so uh let so that's the modified
algorithm we call it ppsc
and um to stand for the authors
of the paper and um
um right
so let me talk about the analysis so the
analysis is a lot more complicated now
okay it's complicated doubly complicated
first of all even for a de-isolated case
so we have to go through more
complicated calculations to figure out
so the average probability of
a forcing before the average probability
of forcing is simple
if all clauses have length k a length
bounded by k
the probability of forcing a variable
that is making that variable appear as a
unit clause
under random permutations 1 in k so
that's simple
but then if you have clauses of very
critical clauses are varying length for
the same variable
so you have to look at the uh
look at the so so you have to look at
the probability of that variable
appearing
as the last variable in the ordering for
one of the critical clauses
so that's going to be and that's going
to be a very messy calculation
we don't even know precisely what are
going to be the critical clauses
and the resolution is going to produce
them and then we have to argue over the
resolution
and the lengths will be varied and there
will be shared variables among critical
clauses
okay or they could be disjoint
so for so that requires a particular
technique and we introduce the notion of
a critical clause
tree to manage or to
to keep track of all the critical
clauses we produce through resolution
actually not all of them actually we
keep track of a subset of them
and that critical velocity is quite
helpful in tracking the
probability of forcing and uh and that's
how we get the result for the
de-isolation case
so that's the first set of difficulties
then
to again to extend the case to the
general kcnf
it turned out to be kind of extremely
hard so we worked for several years
and we were able to extend the same
result for k five or more
for three and four there was some gap
and thankfully timo hartley came
up with a much more um a much nicer
analysis
and simpler analysis and that takes the
isolated case de-isolated case to the
general case
and with exactly the same bonds okay so
together we have a complete algorithm
now
for the general kcnf so let me give you
the intuition
for that for the de-isolated case okay
so um so basically as i said um
that we okay we develop a tree that
keeps track of the critical clauses
generated
uh some of the critical clauses
generated by resolution
okay so we keep flipping bits along each
path so that means we look at the next
we'll look at the next faraway
non-satisfying assignment
that implies some clause must be true
and we take advantage of that clause and
resolve and then produce one more
critical clause
so the critical class tree basically is
a tree labeled with uh
can label with variable and the root is
x1 so let's say we're talking about
critical
clause for x1 and along each path
we have so the variables are distinct
and the cuts of this
tree correspond to critical clauses so
the cut is a cut
so we have a set of variables which acts
as a cut so you take x1
and then take the negations of these cut
variables that defines the critical
class
so that's how we keep track of a subset
of critical clauses
and uh and then we can talk about the
probability of a random permutation
cutting the string
or producing a producing a cut for this
trick
so so through through careful
calculations we could do
so we were able to prove that that
the probability of outputting
for any de-isolated solution the
probability of outputting
is basically slightly better than 1 in k
and mu k c mu k
is basically limit of mu k is one point
six four four so previously we had one
in k for savings
and now we have one point six four four
over k minus one
okay
so with that so so that also shows that
this also shows that the number of
de-isolated solutions is bounded by the
quantity
and we can then use this to prove
stronger lower bounds for depth three
circuits slightly stronger lower bonds
okay where the product of the log of the
fan in times
times the bottom fan in is strictly more
than n
so so you take an error correcting code
where the solutions are guaranteed to be
isolated
and the bottom fan in is k so such a
case c and f cannot accept more than
uh so many solutions that are isolated
from each other sufficiently well
and so we get a lower bond on the number
of kcnfs required
um and that can be generalized
to deal with uh uh to deal with
arbitrary depth three circuits
and that will give us a lower bond of so
two to the one point two eight two
times square
question for problems that have only one
solution
is that when the the limit
i mean is that when that limit is useful
you can you can use
the limit is as k goes to infinity
yeah so for
for problems with only one solution um
right so there is no improvement
so the same the same bound applies
but what what about is i should say i
guess as d goes to infinity
like right so one would expect as
get more and more isolation can we
improve upon this and we could only yeah
we could not exploit that fact
so things yeah so we basically assume
the critical class tree has distinct
variables allowed
so that that's how we're able to um
kind of look at the external case and
then
so then only we can analyze that
so let me do one more slide and then we
can stop okay
um so for the general case as i
mentioned
so the analysis or the extension turned
out to be much
much more complicated and uh and we had
to use various
um ways of balancing various things
and and we could only extend it for k
greater than or equal to five
but with a with a nicer and uningenious
analysis timo has
solved the problem after 10 years after
the first publication
and he extended the result nicely for
all k
and with a much simpler analysis but but
the analysis builds on the unique case
or the de-isolated case
so that's the basis and can extending it
to
to the general case and also this
algorithm is such that we could not
extend it we could not show improved
bound of the same exponent
when the number of solutions is larger
so in the case of ppg
as the number of solutions is larger so
we get proportionate improvement
okay 2 to the n over the number of
solutions to the power 1 minus 1 over k
so that's expression so you would like
similar kind of thing for ppsc but we
could not prove that
so you would like to preserve the
exponent 1 minus mu k
of 1 minus mu k over k minus 1
and and have the base be 2 to the n over
s
that we could not do okay so uh
there is there is some thinking that uh
that uh um right
so in the in the last uh
so that little of one term was all based
on the
distance uh right so in his
arguments does that lula of one term go
away it's just two to the n minus one
over
one minus mu k over k minus one with
right so that's the clean
bound yeah that's a clean bond yeah that
little one comes
due to the distance see if we take
distance and that's the
best known uh for every k
or that's the best known for every k
but for k equals three teemo has a small
improvement in the
in a in a very small way that's my
understanding
i didn't fully go through the paper um
if anyone remember
i believe it's the tenth decimal or
seventh decimal is
the small improvement for k equals three
so that's basically the state of the arc
today
but for that improvement from from timo
um right so that could not be that was
not extended to k equals four or five
and uh
so actually uh timor had a slightly
different modification of our algorithm
that
we were aware of that he
instead of doing resolution in the first
step and then just running
the algorithm he does resolution after
each choice
and this in principle you can get larger
clauses because after you set
certain variables then possibly
the clauses that you generate may be
larger if you did it at the beginning
we are not able to use this and he used
this
in his paper but is this essential or
for this analysis or has anybody
analyzed
the original one it simplifies
uh um i think his weight function the
way he balances various things
when you have too many solutions he he
there is some argument
and so so that's what we try to do so we
try to balance
when you have too few solutions so you
so use some other argument
and we have too many use some other
argument so he balances them much more
nicely more elegantly
so that's the key so that's the key to
his result
but is it essential that he uses this
resolution and each step his proof is
looks like it's essential but but i
didn't think uh
i think of doing it otherwise
what then you walk down on the
gridironization of the ppsz
algorithm the randomization um
yeah so there is so there is there are
several results
um i'm trying to see whether the
constant is preserved
so the bound is 2 to the n times 1 minus
1 over k
i i'm not sure if there is a d
randomization where the constant is
preserved
um but but the so there are d randomizer
so there are deterministic algorithms of
the type 2 to the n times 1 minus c over
k
so 1 over k format is preserved
i'm not sure of the best constraint
i do believe yeah i yeah francis pvc
like the random permutation thing by
just using that ky's independence
or something or even almost
the problem is that this works for the
unique
set but if you have general set then
okay i was going to ask what goes wrong
yes so we get a slightly larger con
a slightly larger constant there sorry
smaller constant
c or k yeah smaller
smaller savings
i didn't follow the more recent results
about the randomization ppsd
randomization
is still an open question
any other questions yeah so from the
other side are there lower bounds on
ksat based on let's say strong gta
like how far can you push the dependence
on k
so so we'll talk about that so
um right so there are some lower bounds
so if you look at the con okay so let me
uh make the following definition
for each k let uh sigma k be the best
con
sigma k be the best constant
for the exponent so assuming eth we show
that uh
uh so so this sequence of constants is
increasing
or non-decreasing so that's a kind of
lower bond so that's what led to the
strong
that ethos actually answer the question
asked which i think is we should
probably put on the open questions
list which is assuming strong eth
or any fixed k can we argue
that the constant has to be at least a
certain quantity
and i you know i don't see that like if
we came up with a 2 to the .001
algorithm for 3sat that would so that's
one of the open questions in the third
talk
right
so um right
so for example significantly improving
the constant
the savings from one in k to one in log
log k
or log log k uh i will have implications
uh for uh for for circuit lower bonds
so basically all the known algorithms so
they know it
so they know attempted i mean there's no
success so far in improving
um the form of the solution which is one
in case savings
11 is that right yeah 11.
okay